[Musik]
salam aleikum meine lieben freunde
herzlich willkommen hier heute schon
mittlerweile zur dritten episode
minecraft mit luca staffel 2 wir sehen
dort ganz hin und der mond geht auf und
die sonne geht unter in unserer kleinen
blumen tulpen landschaft hier deswegen
würde ich mal ganz fix schlafengehen mit
einer fackel und meinen weizen fördern
in der hand so dass wir einen frischen
schönen neuen tag wie heute zur
verfügung haben denn den brauchen wir
auch und den müssen wir auch wirklich
vollends ausnutzen denn mir wurde
zahlreichen kommentare geschrieben erst
mal nur luca es war kein stiegen hier
anders b daher laufe ich direkt mal fix
zurück sondern war sperren dahin und
werde mich mal ganz kurz bei ihm
persönlich dafür entschuldigen
auf dem weg dorthin müssen wir
allerdings direkt einige sachen
mitnehmen zum beispiel nehmen wir
einfach mal unsere schere und gönnen uns
hier ist das eichenlaub das ist ein
perfekter versuchen sie nicht
[Musik]
weg ich setze hier mal ganz kurz eine
fackel hin wir haben wirklich eine menge
höhlen hier ist auch so ein kleiner gang
die höhle scheint allerdings relativ
klein zu sein das sehen wir direkt ihr
dann schon
also mal ganz kurz die eben die ganze
kohle mitnehmen
[Musik]
so die kohle haben wir abgebaut und das
eisen habe ich auch noch mitgenommen ich
glaube auch dass das gerade tatsächlich
die allererste kleine time labs in dem
projekt minecraft mit luca staffel zwei
war wir konzentrieren ist allerdings gar
nicht mal so groß
[Musik]
ach jetzt bin ich an meinem kreis
gelaufen ich idiot ich wollte sagen dass
wir uns ja heute gar nicht mal so doll
auf höhen konzentrieren wollen die erste
richtige höhlen episode lässt auf jeden
fall noch auf sich warten wird demnächst
kommen wir benötigen erstmal hier eine
menge
fichtenstämme und dementsprechend auch
eine menge fichtenholz denn ihr seht es
bereits im titel und ihr habt es
wahrscheinlich auch schon beim samuel
gesehen ich baue heute meine erste
eigene
basin meinen geschafft und das wird eine
underground base ich habe mir gedacht
warum wir uns nochmal das häuschen bauen
ich kann auch einfach mir untergrund
mäßig was bauen dann nimmt keinen platz
weg + ich weiß noch nicht so richtig in
welche richtung dass er alles geben wird
was ich genau alles noch bauen möchte
mir wurde auch wir wohl noch ganz ganz
viele ideen in die kommentare
geschrieben beispielsweise doch ein
fettes baumhaus dorf wo dann
beispielsweise auch die willicher darin
leben können das wäre natürlich auch
eine geile idee aber das ist natürlich
erstmal noch zukunftsmusik ich hab halt
noch fast keine materialien hier so ein
bisschen mohn werde ich jetzt auch
einfach mal mitnehmen denn das benötige
ich nachher für teppiche die ich mir
färben möchte für meine underground base
und auch für einen kleinen blumentopf
den ich mir dort hinstellen möchte dann
natürlich gleich denkt direkt wieder auf
so ein bisschen deko hier haben wir
wären
[Musik]
das waren die bären
die habe ich in staffel 1 schon immer
angegriffen aber da wurde mir auch ganz
in die kommentare geschrieben luca
können jedoch einfach seegras das ist
zwar jetzt nicht so nahrhaft aber zu
beginn reicht es auf jeden fall aus und
ich kann mir dadurch auf jeden fall so
ein bisschen leben zurückholen ich es
noch mal eben kurz die so süß wäre hier
dann habe ich das leben auf jeden fall
wiederholen kann ein bisschen
regenerieren und vor allem endlich
wieder sprinten und wir können jetzt
endlich mal nach den waschbären suchen
bei denen ich mich entschuldigen wollte
hallo misst das schaf schafe können wir
auch mal ganz kurz scheren denn wir
benötigen auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen wolle einerseits für die
teppiche was ich mir überlegt hat ob
perfekt direkt neue wolle hier bekommen
sondern auch noch für ein weiteres bett
was ich mir machen wollte ob gott
ich werde dieses bären hier jetzt auch
mal abbauen denn ich weiß dass ich das
mit dem seegras machen kann aber das ist
immer so ein bisschen stressig weil da
muss jetzt alles abbauen da musste das
erst mal wieder ein ofen backen und ich
glaube dann nehme ich mir erstmal hier
so ein bisschen süß bären mit und kann
die dann quasi bei mir zu hause da ein
bisschen an pflanzen
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob der freundliche ist
oder nicht
[Musik]
was sind das für holz hatten hier
war hier nicht auch
irgendwo oder bin ich gerade wird und
vertun mich aber war hier nicht irgendwo
auch diese
hexe
ist eine hexe das wollten wir auch und
in die kommentare geschrieben dass diese
hütte eine hexe gehört das hatten wir an
der kompletten minecraft staffel eins
nicht entdeckt aber hier ist wirklich
nicht passieren dass ver erste da vorne
es gibt so viele sachen zu entdecken die
sonne geht allerdings schon unter meine
lieben freunde von daher sprinte ich mal
zurück zu meiner pace die noch nicht
existiert da vorne haben wir irgendwo
unsere sachen hingestellt also den
crafting table den ofen unters bett viel
mehr besitzen wir leider noch nicht
vollständig bei mir schon immer reden
die wir haben
die teile müssen wir auch noch entdecken
aber diese haben fakten mich jetzt
gerade schon wieder ab na ja meine
lieben freunde die sonne geht unter ich
finde so unfassbar schöne ich hätte
nicht gedacht dass ich das nach staffel
1 minecraft mit luca noch mal sage aber
ich finde dieser map wirklich deutlich
geiler jetzt schon als meine erste map
weil wir einfach viel mehr zu entdecken
haben wir haben in staffel eins einfach
diese kleine insel gab und das war ganz
cool dass wir daraus geschaffen haben
aber hier gibt es so viel
das warenzeichen schlafen zu geben ich
würde auch sagen dass ich euch jetzt die
zweite teil maps eine blende wie ich mir
alle sachen erstmal vorbereitet die ich
für meine underground base benötige
[Musik]
hier ist es eigentlich auch recht schön
ist eine kleine bucht und ein
angedeuteter sehe und auch überall so
blätter und so aber bei der lieben
freundin merkt schon die teilnahme ist
vorbei ich habe mir alle sachen besorgt
unser sport ist ja hinten so ein
bisschen an den vorläufen von diesem
schnee bio da müssen wir auch unbedingt
noch rein ich bin echt gespannt ob es
auch irgendwelche schnee im monster gibt
oder irgendwelche einer was sind denn so
steht ihre so welche rentiere
schneemänner pinguine keine ahnung ob
sowas auch gibt die sache ist allerdings
dass wir jetzt endlich mal anfangen
werden und dafür habe ich mir hier vorne
schon eine kiste hingestellt mit allen
dingen die ich benötige werde allerdings
jetzt erst mal eine andere tour nehmen
und hier alle sachen reinpacken die ich
erst mal nicht benötige einfach so dass
wir ein bisschen platz haben für diese
ganzen dinge denn hier werde ich die
truhe jetzt auch einfach mal ab und
haben wir alles direkt im inventar und
wir können direkt starten das bett hier
kommt auch weg und hier vorne kommt auch
der ofen weg plus die werkbank das wird
nämlich auch nach unten gemacht in
unsere underground base wir fangen jetzt
einfach mal direkt damit den
fichtenstämmen und zwar setzen wir hier
vorne beispielsweise ein hin und dann im
3 block abstand hier einen dann wieder
drei blöcke abstand hier einen und
wieder drei blöcke abstand und dann hier
wo die orangene pulp es hier auch noch
ein handy teile hier bauen wir therapie
benötigen wir nämlich nichts sagt und
hier vorne und jetzt können wir uns hier
erstmal auf die wände konzentrieren das
wären keine richtigen wende sondern
nur so in die art dass man das
angedeutet kriegt das es ja irgendwie
runter geht deswegen hier jetzt erstmal
fichtenholz stufen hin und her
fichtenholz ich liebe fichtenholz hier
vorne kommt dann auf jeden fall eine
fichtenholz falsche hin denn das hier
ist unser eingang seien nach unten und
hier können wir uns dann auch direkt ein
bisschen runter bauen
[Musik]
wir benutzen natürlich für die ganzen
arbeiten hier erst mal auf unsere stein
spitzhacke damit wir hier wirklich
nichts verschwenden und dann
schlussendlich wegschmeißen müssen also
hier den blog auch noch abbauen und
jetzt wünschen wir zu unseren
fichtenholz brettern denn wir kleistern
jetzt hier alles mit fichtenholz aus ich
habe mich jetzt eins zwei drei vier
blöcke runter gegraben und mache jetzt
hier den boden auf die fünfte ebene hin
an den seiten ziehen wir jetzt hier die
fichten holzstämme einfach runter
beziehungsweise hoch wie man es nehmen
will und dann findet sich das ganze
quasi auch hier unten wieder was oben
angedeutet wird durch diese kleinen
knubbel hier die wand ragen wie auch ab
denn hier kommt auf fichtenholz hin
ausser der oberste blog davon gleich
wieder erde hin hier vorne allerdings
genau das gleiche zack zack zack den
habe ich jetzt aussehen abgebaut da
kommt allerdings auch eher dahin denn
das werdet ihr gleich schon sehen diese
blöcke sieht man halt von außen und ich
will nicht dass wenn man dann oben da
lang läuft das dann plötzlich irgendwie
fichtenholz ist oder so jetzt nehmen wir
unsere leitern davon hab ich mit 15
stück gemacht dass man ein bisschen
bisschen
übermütig
umgeht die sonne schwiegermutter wir
können die zeit allerdings direkt mal
nutzen um mich hier unsere kohle rein zu
packen und den sand den ich mir vorhin
gerade dort hinten geholt habe dann mit
dem nötigen auch noch glas das soll
nämlich oben dann so ein bisschen drauf
kommen was hier oben allerdings auch
erst mal drauf kommen sind stein
druckplatten hier vorne so ein bisschen
als deko da könnte man auch laterne
hinsetzen mit so einer kleinen
steinmauer drauf allerdings dachte ich
mir dass er mich irgendwann so
verschiedene wege haben uns so dass das
hier vielleicht auch schlussendlich dann
ich brauche erstmal ganz kurz mal ein
bettchen hier noch mal provisorisch dass
sich hier schlafen gehen kann ich habe
mir halt auf jeden fall gedacht dass
alles so ein bisschen verbunden wird mit
so ein paar wegen ich habe auch schon
ein youtube video gesehen wo jemand
aufnahme ist sie ein riesiges feld
gebaut hat mit tieren und farben und so
da hätte ich auch total bock drauf was
ich habe auf jeden fall einige ideen
also stay tuned
nicht verpassen wollte allerdings müssen
wir jetzt erstmal hier uns ein bisschen
glas rausnehmen denn ich will ja nicht
dass wir uns gleich irgendwie anfangen
sollte zuschneiden dass wir dann hier
unten gegen die eine menge schnee
drinnen haben weil ich weiss nicht wenn
es hier regnet ob dann der schnee von
hier vorne mit rüber kommt oder so jetzt
haben wir hier das glas allerdings auch
schon fertig gebraten und können hier
vorne zack zack sagt das ganze so
hinsetzen der rest kommt ihre einig lass
das glas einfach mal noch hier drin glas
ist nie schlecht
merkt euch das ihr
könnt auch richtig was mitnehmen hier
aus dem projekt naja hier vorne kommen
auf jeden fall jetzt auch noch
fichtenstämme hin ihr wisst ich liebe
fichtenholz das weiß man nicht erst seit
meinem kreft staffel 1 und jetzt haben
wir auch noch hier vorne pflichten
holztreppe die könnten erzielen setzen
und hier dann sehr dass ganz geil aus
ich habe mir allerdings gedacht dass wir
vielleicht auch so ein bisschen was
grünes jahre einbringen sollten zum
beispiel solchen laub und dafür hab ich
mir dann extra und auch einen blumentopf
gemacht und ich habe mir auch noch
mitgenommen habe ich hier unten direkt
schon drin dann sieht dass sie nämlich
so aus dann können wir hier noch eine
kleine laterne irgendwie beispielsweise
hinhängen zack damit ihr schon mal ein
bisschen beleuchtung und ich habe noch
eine rüstung ständer gemacht ich hab
zwar noch keine rüstung allerdings ist
das auf jeden fall das ziel dass ich
hier noch rüstungen kriegen werde
wow eigentlich hinaus
so jetzt graben bei uns ja allerdings in
jeden gang von diesen seiten das sind
eigentlich keine richtigen gänge
allerdings in jedes abteil hier ist noch
keine abteile aber ihr wisst was ich
meine auf jeder seite bauen wir uns
jetzt auf jeden fall einen block weiter
rein denn hier wird jetzt alles so ein
bisschen schöner gemacht zum beispiel
benutzen wir jetzt unsere fichtenholz
treppen um mich hier einfach mal drei
hinzusetzen und hier drei hinzusetzen
jetzt müssen wir allerdings natürlich
auch diese seiten hier ein bisschen
schöner machen und genau das gleiche
hier vorne auch ihr seht gleich schon
warum wir kommen jetzt nämlich noch
fichtenholz bretter reihen genauso wie
hier vorne und auch hier und hier nutzen
jetzt den platz für fest
[Musik]
wir nutzen jetzt den platz für fächer
und genau das machen wir auch hier vorne
denn dann können wir jetzt hier vor
[Musik]
denn da können wir jetzt hier vor
beispielsweise eine truhe setzen hier
dann noch eine truhe und ihren ofen und
hier vorne machen wir das gleiche
nochmal hier mit dem ofen mit einer
werkbank und hier kommt dann der andere
oben hin denen wir jetzt gerade noch
hier oben stehen haben den brauch ich
mal ganz fix wieder ab und dann können
wir auch die sachen hier unten in der
halle
so dann können wir uns nämlich noch ein
ofen hinsetzen und ihr seht doch schon
das ist hier ein bisschen dunkel
irgendwie alles deswegen würde ich sagen
nehmen wir unsere verkennen die ich hier
vorne habe und setzten hier einfach mal
zwei fackeln dran und hier und hier auch
in den boden da hab ich mir eine kleine
sache habe ich da gesehen die man hier
machen kann und zwar nie so weit runter
müssen wir gar nicht gegen luca da kann
ich mal ganz kurz im kurzfilm einen
stein nehmen und den hinsetzen denn wir
können uns eine fackel nehmen die hier
hinsetzen und nehmen jetzt einfach
unseren roten teppich um warm zu machen
und jetzt haben wir sie quasi so eine
kleine indirekte beleuchtung das werden
über nacht sehen wenn die sonne hier
nicht so rein knallt allerdings müssen
wir uns jetzt auch nur noch um unser
kleines schlafgemach tier kümmern da
kommen nämlich hier jetzt erstmal
fichtenholz bretter reihen komplett zack
zack und jetzt hier ein bett und darüber
auch ein bett und hier dann fichtenholz
falltüren und hier darüber auch nicht
mal schön wenn man die herzlich ein
klappt sie
wenn man die jetzt für mich ein klappt
die das ganze so oft die sonne art
hochbett und jetzt können wir ganz easy
hier einfach noch so eine kleine laterne
dranhängen und dann haben wir es auch
schon
[Musik]
wir haben hier verstauben möglichkeiten
hier versteuern möglichkeiten wir immer
noch hier zwei truhen für extra sachen
und wir haben drei öfen plus eine
werkbank wir haben alles schön
ausgeleuchtet allerdings nicht zu hell
wir haben hier und lauda eine kleine
indirekte beleuchtung wir können unsere
rüstungen hier anpacken und haben auch
ein bisschen deko und von außen
denkt man gar nicht dass sich hier
darunter so ein kleines platzwunder
befindet
wir zerstören nicht unsere landschaft
wohnen unter der erde haben trotzdem
licht und verstauen möglichkeiten
ein paar sekunden später ich habe jetzt
gerade nochmal meine items ein bisschen
sortiert das hat auch nur anderthalb
minuten gedauert und dann dachte ich mir
mensch davon bräuchte jetzt keinesfalls
einblenden hier habe ich so ein bisschen
steinen sachen reingepackt der rest hier
ist noch leer ich habe wie gesagt noch
nicht so viele sachen hier vornehmlich
noch ein bisschen reisen reingepackt was
schon mal so ein bisschen vor sich hin
berät hier habe ich mit passieren die
selteneren sache oder eingelegt es ist
traurig dass ich gerade noch sage dass
kohle und eisen und kupfer für mich
selten ist aber hier auf jeden fall dann
so ein bisschen werkzeug die sachen habe
ich jetzt erstmal inventar und hier habe
ich heute sachen eingepackt habe ich so
ein bisschen in sachen eingepackt wo ich
nicht genau weiß wohin damit erde wolle
und glas und habe ich ein bisschen
natürliche sachen eingepackt wie
beispielsweise blumen körner et cetera
hier oben befindet sich nichts mehr hier
ist weder eine kiste noch mein bett und
ich werde jetzt auch einfach mal die
türe hierzu manchmal meine erste nacht
in der base verbringen meine lieben
freunde in unserem kleinen hochbett hier
vorne ich freue mich auf jeden fall wir
haben so einen kleinen punkt wo wir
jetzt mal wieder hingehen können und
dann gehen wir nach oben und sehen
direkt den sonnenaufgang und wissen dass
hier unsere bases aber es ist trotzdem
ein geschmeckt in die natur ich freue
mich auf jeden fall meine lieben freunde
auf die nächste episode was soll ich
machen schreibt mir gern und in die
kommentare ich habe selber eine menge
pläne aber wenn er irgendwie wollte dass
sich beispielsweise noch ein paar neue
tiere entdeckt wenn ich tatsächlich der
nächste folge dann schon mal zu diesem
hexenhaus dahinter hingehen soll was
soll ich machen schreibt in die
kommentare ihr dürft mitbestimmen wenn
es euch gefallen hat er das gern einen
daumen unter dem video abonniert main
kanal und krieg auf die glocke wenn ihr
die nächste episode ist minecraft mit
luca morgen pünktlich um 18 uhr nicht
verpassen wollte
[Musik]